soldatinnen soldaten
wir werden in den nächsten monaten
anderes erfahren während in den nächsten
monaten möglicherweise in situationen
kommen die er bis dato nicht erlebt hat
ich kann ihnen versichern und kann euch
versichern dass wir die ausbildung
entsprechend machen dass sie gut
ausgebildet sein werden
sie werden kameradschaft erfahren sie
werden gemeinschaft erfahren
ich bitte sie nehmen sie diese
möglichkeiten an
nehmen sie an dass sie in einer
organisation wie das österreichische
bundesheer auch für andere da sein
werden möglicherweise auch im rahmen des
katastrophenschutzes möglicherweise auch
im rahmen des assistenzeinsatzes es ist
ein zeichen der zeit dass wir diese
möglichkeiten und diese maßnahmen für
die gemeinschaft da zu sein
für den staat zu dienen auch annehmen
nehmen sie diese zeit ernst lernen sie
aus dieser zeit und leben sie
kameradschaft in diesem sinne darf ich
ihnen viel soldaten glück wünschen
sehr geehrte damen und herren sowie sich
das bundesheer den neuen bedrohungen
stellt reagiert es auch auf
veränderungen in unserer gesellschaft
heute spiegelt das bundesheer die
diversität unseres landes in weiten
teilen wieder menschen
unterschiedlichster herkunft dienen der
republik im österreichischen bundesheer
wenn sie heute am nationalfeiertag ihr
gelöbnis als soldatinnen und soldaten
republik österreich ablegen werden dann
tun sie dies in der gewissheit in einem
heer zu dienen dass sich werten wie
verantwortung schutz der demokratie
achtung der menschenrechte
frieden und solidarität verschrieben
haben
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
es lebe die republik österreich